die wasserwerfer werden jetzt
tatsächlich eingesetzt die polizei geht
jetzt also gegen diejenigen
demonstranten vor die sich nicht daran
halten dass die demo seit mittlerweile
fast einer halben stunde für beendet
erklärt worden ist wir sehen hier die
bilder zwei wasserwerfer die jetzt also
bereits die demonstranten dort nass
gemacht haben wir uns gerade von den
kollegen hans raab gehört natürlich soll
das dafür helfen das in der nässe jetzt
im winter ist natürlich extrem kalt wird
die menschen dann also sozusagen dazu
gezwungen sind nach hause zu gehen hier
sehen wir es noch immer wie die
wasserwerfer eingesetzt werden also
vorher hatte die polizei um 12 uhr sechs
die versammlung auf der straße 17 juni
für beendet erklärt hatte getwittert die
ehemaligen demo teilnehmenden haben nun
die pflicht den ehemaligen
versammlungsort zu verlassen
wir haben von unseren kollegen gehört
dass es also immer wieder lautsprecher
ansagen gab dass die menschen jetzt also
unverzüglich dem platz und die straße
räumen sollen dieses nicht passiert und
jetzt also der einsatz von wasserwerfern
wie wir es vorher bereits von der
polizei sprecherin gehört hatten sollten
die demo-teilnehmer dem also nicht folge
leisten genau das ist jetzt passiert wir
sehen die live bilder hier gerade
aktuell vom brandenburger tor also
wirklich nur einen steinwurf entfernt
vom reichstag vom bundestag wo jetzt in
diesen minuten über das
infektionsschutzgesetz debattiert wird
werden von einem kollegen peter titel
gehört das gesetz wird heute mit größter
wahrscheinlichkeit durchgehend es gibt
zwar noch einige kritikpunkte sind
dennoch der großteil der politiker wird
dafür stimmen
und hier auf den straßen in berlin rund
um den reichstag also tausende
demonstranten die jetzt dazu
aufgefordert werden nach hause zu gehen
und mittlerweile werden sogar
wasserwerfer dafür eingesetzt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren